since the last time I saw you you became
a father congratulations thank you how
old is she now she's four she's four
years old that's a great age really fun
at four and here's a kind of an
interesting like it's it's I didn't
realize this till today that her
grandfather is Rod Stewart so you hang
out with Rod Stewart sometimes you've
gone to Disneyland with Rod Stewart is
that right yeah that's nuts crazy what's
it like to be on a ride with Rod Stewart
at Disneyland Hot Stuff hot legs do you
think that's so crazy I can't imagine it
that's cool it's cool you know he knows
what rides to hit when he goes to want
to go to Disneyland
I don't even know what that means I'm
going to go straight to Pirates of the
Caribbean oh yeah he knows what to do
no mr. Toad's Wild Ride oh yeah yeah Oh
mr. toad has some fans I know I
seriously I seriously bummed out a
section Brad they're like oh oh you the
guy dressed as a toad in the crowd who's
crying now what kind of I'm curious at
4:00 I remember that's the age I started
to get to watch movies with my daughter
are you watching movies with her what
kind of movies does she like you know I
I played I put et and she watched it all
the way and at the very end when et gets
on the ship and he goes mm-hmm
I turn around and she is crying and then
she turns to me and she goes I need et
where is et bring him back so I had to
watch the movie again
so the movies on a loop but leaving well
no but I cut right before oh I see okay
before gets on the bike and he goes up
in the air I go okay babies time to go
to sleep yeah that's good he's gonna
stick around he's not going any not
going anywhere
yeah you just put on freeze-frame that's
what you do yeah I run it in reverse
et comes back
that's the secret for all of these watch
any old movies you ever watch old
classics we put I put um Charlie Chaplin
oh great yeah it's great it's great and
she goes she goes what are they saying
silent is a silent movie okay what are
they saying what are they saying
but just listen just listen yeah he's
gonna think there's something wrong with
their hear I can't you hear it I hear it
yeah those are the mind games I play
with my daughter you don't hear it oh
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please